foreign
welcome to the simply learned YouTube
channel in today's video we are going to
be talking about how to start a blog and
we'll be discussing what is a block what
is a blog post should you start a blog
how do you start a blog and what are the
pros and the cons of blogging in the
process of presenting all this to you I
will share some interesting blogs with
you and I will also share some cool
tools that you can use in developing
your blog setting up your blog and
writing your blog post but before all
this I am Mark Mark campman I'm your
digital navigator for this video and if
you like the video press the like button
and of course if you want to subscribe
to our Channel click on the Subscribe
button below so are you ready let me
start with giving you a few facts about
blogs did you know that there are over
more than 600 million blogs on the
internet
over 2 million blog posts are published
every day
77 of Internet users they regularly read
blogs and articles that include visuals
like photos or Graphics or videos they
in general get up over 90 percent more
views than those articles without
visuals
when it comes to blogging platforms one
of the most popular popular blogging
platforms is Tumblr over
495 million blogs but for businesses
they it is not used that much there are
the more popular platforms for
um for businesses and WordPress is one
of them there are 60 million blogs
powered by WordPress
and blogs are the second most common
form of media used in content marketing
yeah so some really exciting facts about
blogging and about the the number of
blogs on the internet but let's dive
right into it and let's go into what are
we going to be talking about first of
all what does a blog stand for yeah so
let's discuss that in the context of the
timeline of the history of blogs so
blogs they sort of emerged around just
when the internet came about in 1994
1995 and there was a good guy called
Justin Hall he started a personal blog
while he was studying at say a college
in America becoming one of the first
widely read bloggers
in the late 90s when the internet was
bit more accepted the first blogs are
created primarily serving as personal
journals for a small group of friends or
for your family
in the early 2000s blogging tools and
blogging Services became widely
available and this is also when I had my
first exposure to blogs when my son went
on a gap year and he traveled to Asia to
Vietnam and to um to Cambodia and he
uploaded his photos in internet's cafes
that he found in those countries for his
travel blog so it made it very easy in
those early days for people to create
and maintain their own blog in 2002 the
term blog was coined and became widely
used to describe a website that serves
as an online journal or diary and that's
where the term blog came from like it
was a a web log it was a big log it was
a big web it helps you to read the web
yeah so different angles but the overall
term block becomes used to describe a
website light that serves as an online
journal or a diary so a web log is kind
of the closest to what a Blog really
stands for
so it then started to become very
popular in the sort of the
2005-2010 era when it started to be
picked up by businesses as well the wide
range of topics and styles from personal
journals to photography blogs to recipe
blogs and people really started to see
the power of blogging and in 2010 and
onwards it became a mainstream form of
communication and self-expression with
millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving every
possible audience and businesses really
jumped on this and today it is one of
the most significant roles being played
by blogs in the rise of social media and
it is a profound impact on the way
people communicate and consume
information online
yeah so that is a short introduction of
blogging let's have a quick look at what
we're going to be talking about first
I'm going to be digging into a Blog what
is a Blog and then what is a blog post
and what are the characteristics of blog
posts because clearly a Blog and a blog
post is different than a default or a
standard web page next question is that
we're going to answer should you start a
blog yeah some people they are excited
about blogging and they go straight into
it where other people they're not quite
sure yeah so let me give you some tips
and guidelines if you want to start a
blog and when you want to start it how
do you start a blog so that's what we'll
be looking at as well and then we'll
close today's session with a look at the
pros and cons of starting a blog and in
the meantime in the process of
presenting all this I will share with
you lots of tools lots of suggestions
and lots of ideas
on starting your own blog
so let's talk about the features of a
Blog what is a Blog now a blog is a type
of website serving as an online journal
or a diary
and a Blog consists of a number of posts
on a particular topic or a theme
okay so that is it's a blog post it's
kind of the container for a range of
Articles around a particular theme now
it can be created by individuals it can
be created by companies by businesses
organizations serving various purposes
it could be for personal expression of
ideas it could be for marketing it could
be for journalism or even for activism
the beauty about the blog is that it is
so easily created and managed using
blogging software or blogging services
and all that software and all those
services are available online some are
for free some are premium but it is very
easy to get started with your blog and
those blogging software platforms they
include features such as commenting
systems so that allows you to get your
engagement with your readers
so it is based as a standalone website
or on social media networks or content
Management Systems yep so there's
different ways that you can set up your
blog but it places significant rise in
the growth of certain integrals of
social media and as a profound impact on
the way people communicate and the way
people consume information
so then what is a blog post a blog post
is any article any news piece or guide
that is published in the blog section of
website
okay so it typically covers a specific
topic or topic or a query and it's in
the educational in nature and it ranges
from 600 to 2000 two and a half thousand
words
the typical blog includes the title
title is very important the title
conveys the topic of the post
it then has a body of text with in-depth
information and commentary on the topic
it then has images or multimedia
elements like video or infographics to
illustrate a content and it's very
important to visualize what you're
trying to say in your blog post
other important elements of your blogs
are hyperlinks to other resources that
you use to form your opinion about what
you're writing about
and very important because when you have
a Blog you will have many articles so
you want to give people access to all
those articles as well and EC access so
they use in blocks they use categories
or tags to categorize and organize all
the blog posts and you can search in
those categories search in those tags to
access other blog posts
good blogs also contain contain a
commenting system for reader feedback
there are sharing buttons for social
media sharing there's a publication date
and there is also a short byline of the
author with a biography or a description
yeah so those are the typical
characteristics of a blog post that you
will find in any blog
so as I said earlier a blog post
incorporates visual elements like photos
videos in photographics even interactive
charts to make the topic that is being
written about come to life to explain a
topic or answer a question and they are
very important because first of all they
grab your attention
yeah because visuals are more
eye-catching than text and can quickly
grab the reader's attention making them
more likely to continue to read a post
visuals also help you to break up the
texts large block of text
can be quite overwhelming for readers so
when you add visuals in between those
large blogs it becomes more visually
appealing
it also helps in explaining the topic so
people have a better understanding of
what you're trying to talk about visuals
can help you illustrate complex Concepts
and ideas so it's easier to understand
but also easier to retain
another important aspect of visuals is
that you can evoke emotions particularly
when you are using video in your blog
post as well so it makes the reading
experience more engaging more memorable
likes it as well when you have visuals
or videos in your blog post it really
helps you with your search engine
optimization
yes so it's easier for readers to find a
post than in search engines yeah like
Google or Bing or Yahoo
and then finally visuals they play a
crucial role in enhancing the reader's
experience and make the blog post more
effective in presenting and explaining
and conveying the information and ideas
a really good
um
blog that uses visuals in a very good
way is social mediaexaminer.com yeah I
really like social media examiner he's a
typical blog it is almost like not
recognizable as a Blog website but it is
based on a huge collection of Articles
covering all topics around social media
and to access their library or visual
posts you go to the about us and here
you have the range of articles on web 3
on Instagram marketing Facebook
marketing YouTube marketing so let's go
to Instagram marketing and immediately
you see
all the content around Instagram yep and
if I go to one of their blog posts how
to use Instagram for business then here
you see immediately there is a visual
that explains the overall blog post and
what it is all about yep and then it
uses visuals as well in the blog post to
make it very clear and explain exactly
how things work and how you should use
specific functionality with links to
other tools and tools resources yeah so
it has a really good visual appeal
making it very easy for subscribers to
consume the content
okay so that is what a blog post in
general is about yep so let's look at a
few more details here yeah another very
important aspect of a Blog is the
writing style
yeah blog posts are typically written in
conversational style or in personal size
style or in
um informal style yeah so blog post they
should have a conversational or an
informal tone as if the writer is
speaking directly to the reader because
that makes it more relatable and more
engaging it's also personal so includes
personal anecdotes personal experience
personal opinions and add a unique human
touch to the blog post you therefore use
an active voice yeah instead of passive
voice so we talk about I think we want
to do this instead of they think they
want to do that
so make it clear and concise which is
allowing it to be easy to read and
understand use Simple language try to
avoid technical jargon
another important aspect of the writing
is the attention grabbing headline it's
a headline that is attention grabbing
clearly articulates what the content of
the post is all about and it encourages
people to read the blog post
people love headings of blog posts or
titles of blog posts with numbers five
things you should do to achieve this or
four things you may have missed
yet then there is the the spirographs
and the subheadings make them short
break the text up in short paragraphs
and use those subheadings for the E to
make it easier for the reader to scan
the article as well and then a very
important aspect of your blog is to make
sure that you have engaging calls to
action
yeah a strong and compelling call to
action can encourage readers to engage
with your content and you can ask for
those call to actions ask people to
comment ask people to share or ask
people to take some other action like
signing up for the blog or signing up
for a newsletter
yes so now of course there is no fixed
method of writing your blog make sure
that you write your blog to the style of
your audience
yeah so be flexible and meet the
specific needs of your target audience
now a key question of course should you
start a blog
yeah some people are natural writers and
it makes sense for them to start a blog
some people haven't got a clue but
they're very passionate about something
yeah and the more passionate you are
about something the easier it will be
for you to share your thoughts and ideas
but before I go into more detail in this
question let's have a look at some of
the most popular blog categories and
let's have some uh an example look at
some example blocks that really stand
out so there are many popular blog
titles but here are some of the most
popular topics first of all there are
lifestyle blogs yeah topics It's Fashion
Beauty Health Wellness travel and food
are very popular they arrange for a wide
appeal and that makes it very personal
and very relevant for readers
second is technology blocks people love
technology blogs and there's always
stuff to write about technology because
it changes so fast there's always news
there's always something exciting to
write whether it's smartphones whether
it's laptops whether it's artificial
intelligence or whether it's virtual
reality
another category that's very popular is
blogs about personal finance helping
people to better understand and manage
their finances with topics ranging from
savings and investing to debt management
and budgeting
Business and Entrepreneurship blogs they
are really cool they're really hot on
the internet whether you want to start a
new business when you want to grow an
existing business there's a huge demand
for information and advice on topics
around Business and Entrepreneurship
various obvious very obvious topic to
blog about is news and current affairs
blogs that cover the latest news and
current affairs they are always popular
whether they focus on a particular area
of Interest like politics or technology
or cover a broad range of topics
then there is creative writing there's
literature those are blogs for writers
for readers blogs about creative writing
and literature where you can get a great
source of inspiration and connection
and then finally there's personal
development and self-improvement blocks
topics like personal growth self-care
self-improvement Health they're very
popular for their relevance to many
people's lives
so these are some of the most popular
block Target topics now there are many
many more the possibilities are endless
but the best topics are often those
topics that align with the blurish
passion and expertise
So within those categories let's have a
look at some really good blogs so we
have here an example block a Beautiful
Mess
which is a personal what was it a um a
lifestyle blog yeah so here you see all
the articles in a very simple graphical
presentation you see the color the theme
that is being used is really good it's a
very sort of mellow mellow color tone
yeah they are linking it to a shop as
well here are brands that they work with
but here you see the typical articles
how to cut a pineapple step by step with
video now the typical example of a
really good title for a blog post it's
how to people love how-to titles it is
step by step so we'll make it easy and
it has a video as well yeah that
explains how to do it so again here you
see the title here you see the author
you can pin it straight on Pinterest you
can jump straight to the recipe here is
some proof social proof yeah here you
can subscribe to the blog you see that
in many blogs the right column is being
used for things like subscribe or access
to categories or
um two tags yeah here you see the blog
post itself here you see hyperlinks to
other articles yep and here are links to
other articles as well and these are
often blogs in the blog posts in this
blog as well with strong visuals
yep and then there should be the video
as well because there wasn't a video
that explains it as well yeah so that is
a really good I really like this blog
very simple linking it to a Hot Topic
today Valentine's Day that is coming up
here is your technology Blog The Verge
totally different more male it's black
and white yeah it is strong it's
powerful very good branding that fits
the technology but the same contact
concept blocks strong visuals a um good
titles yep and then here you have how to
access other blog posts as well which
are the top stories yeah the most
popular articles here is a stream that
you can get
yep so uh here is another stream so very
useful powerful blog and here you have
the categories that they are blogging
about
Business and Entrepreneurship
again another block example very content
driven lots of articles but categorized
in a very logical way money and finance
business news Science and Technology
yeah and here is the latest articles
that we've just added another category
buying investing in business another
category branding yes so really good
accessible content in these these blogs
finally the one the last one I want to
show you is tiny Buddha simple wisdom
for complex life so this is clearly a
personal development and
self-improvement block
yeah here is the latest from the blog
here is some fun and inspiring thoughts
here is to subscribe subscribe and um to
the blog here you see the categories
that they have yep and then here you see
the different blog posts so let's look
at the typical article yeah so here you
have the basic article here is the
headline the the title here is the
visual here's the blog post itself
people love bullets in blog posts people
love lists
yeah links to other articles we talked
about the um the author a little
biography and then here you see the
right hand column yeah there is a bit of
subscribe there is a search of the blog
content and then here is a download a
desktop wallpaper recent topics
yep and then the latest post so typical
format of a very powerful blog post
so yeah so these are just some examples
of some really good blogs yeah that are
covering a wide range of topics
now that should give you some ideas and
some food for thought about whether or
not you should start a blog
so let's dive a bit deeper first of all
you should have a passion for writing
and sharing on a particular topic
yeah so you should have a passion about
a topic it should be your hobby or you
should just want to know learn
everything about a particular topping so
because you know when there is a when
you start blogging fact is it does take
a considerable amount of time and effort
not only to start a blog but also to
maintain it so it's important that you
have a genuine interest in the topic you
want to write about
yeah also you need to have very clear
goals what do you want to achieve with
your blog post or with your blog yeah is
it for driving traffic to your website
is it to become known as an expert is it
just for a hobby yeah do you want to
build a personal brand do you want to
use it for your business
yes so or do you maybe want to build an
online following or an online community
or do you want to document your personal
Journey or progress around a specific
project like your garden that your house
that you're developing or a holiday that
you are having
so all these things can are can be very
important in your decision making
whether or not you should start a blog
but if these are all positive and if you
are very convinced and dedicated from
yes I'm going to start a blog yep then
blogging is a fantastic opportunity for
you
and when you are a business there are so
many advantages so many benefits that
you can get from having a Blog on your
website
it can help you in driving traffic to
your website yeah and the traffic that
comes to your website they will read
your blog post and they will Ex they
will see you more and more as an expert
in your field and it will help you in
turning those web visitors into
prospects so you drive conversions
blogging in my opinion is the easiest
way to kick-start your social media
yeah what is the process you start up
your blog you write a blog post and then
you share that blog post on Twitter on
LinkedIn on Facebook on Instagram yeah
in different formats and you're going to
make sure that your blog title and your
block visual is on as many places on the
internet as possible
people will see the blog post and if
they like it they will click on it and
that will take them to your website and
not only that Google will see your blog
post as well and we'll put your article
higher up in the search engine result
page
so in doing all this you build trust you
can build client relationships in a much
better way it helps you in reinforcing
your brand and it helps you in
differentiating yourself from your
competitors and encourage engagement
with your followers
so now that you understand the basics of
blogging and what a blog post is and
whether or not you should start a blog
let's look into the actual process of
starting a blog what are the things that
you need to look at what are the things
that you need to take into consideration
first of all before you start your blog
you need to understand who you're
writing for
yeah you need to research your target
audience what would they like to learn
more about what are their pain points
what are their interests because you can
write whatever you want but if nobody
reads it yeah then it's not going to
serve you any purpose
in marketing terms we talk about
customer personas you should make
customer personas for your audience
yeah let's have a look here there is a
really good tool which is HubSpot
personas
yeah it's from uh from
um HubSpot a make my Persona tool so
just want to share that with you yeah
there are two elements there is what is
a buyer Persona and there's also a tool
make my Persona so let's talk about what
is a buyer Persona a buyer Persona is a
semi-fictional representation of your
ideal customer based on Market Research
looking on the internet talking to your
colleagues your two sales people or
talking to your customers themselves and
real data that you can find about your
customers and in your case you can
actually change customer with reader who
is your ideal reader reader and what do
you know about the reader
you're then going to look at why do I
need this your day provide structure a
Persona they provide structure and
context for you as the Blogger making it
easier for you to map out the content
yeah and align your topics with the
requirements the reading needs of your
audience
yeah and how do you use them yeah so by
learning about your ideal customer or
your ideal reader their challenges their
goals their demographic traits it helps
you set up a Content strategy
yeah which will increase the chance that
people will read your blog so how do you
create a Persona there's lots of tools
on the internet you can download a guide
here yeah you can also go to back to
um the tool here make my Persona and
that is on HubSpot there is actually a
tool where they can help you build a
persona yeah it will ask you a set of
questions
yeah so created an avatar name your
persona and then it looks at some
demographic characteristics it looks at
some
um some what's it characterizations it
looks at what are their challenges how
do they consume information you can do
that in a walk through mode or you can
also skip the walkthrough mode and then
you go actually into the final version
of the Persona that you can hear filling
in here as well yep so they want to know
the name the title the age level of
Education the social networks that
they're using or reading what is their
preferred method of communication what
are their responsibilities what are
their goals of and objectives what is
the biggest challenge and you can tailor
this completely to your own sort of
reader profile
very useful tool on creating customer
personas a very important part on
starting your blog
once you've started your and created
your persona you're then going to check
out your competition
what are your competitors posting about
yeah how do they approach their target
audience what are the typical topics
that they are looking for yeah so now
there's different ways of finding blocks
from your competitors yeah the
traditional way I would go to Google
yep and I would just search for instance
if I'm in CRM yeah I would just search
on the top 10
blogs on CRM
yep and then here you get lists in
Google of the top CRM blocks
yes so and then you're just gonna have a
look at those blogs you're going to
analyze their content you're going to
look at the topics the formats the tone
and the style you're going to check if
you can get some information about
traffic their social media following
their engagement and maybe you can find
gaps in the content that they are using
yep so there and that those gaps in the
content they are opportunities for you
and maybe you can look at their
promotions that they're running to
gather ideas for your own blog now you
may have heard recently of a new tool
that is out there and that is getting
very a lot of traction in the in the
industry yeah it is a tool called chat
GPT and I had it open somewhere let me
have a look here I don't think I have
let's just go to chat open ai.com
which is a new tool which is what we
call conversational
artificial intelligence and the whole
industry is talking about it it
basically has the potential to replace
Google but time will tell yes so don't
need that yeah so it is basically
conversational
artificial intelligence instead of going
to Google and search for give me the top
10 blogs here I'm just going to ask give
me the top five CRM blogs
yeah and reasons why
they are
so popular
let's see what it comes up with
yeah so you see I'm asking two questions
here give me the top five CRM blocks but
also reasons why they are popular
so this is a whole new way of exploring
content on the internet
and I'm sure in the future we're going
to be using and running a a video where
we're explaining chat GPT in more detail
and how you can use it as a marketeer
but um in the meantime make sure you
have a look at this and look and start
using it for some of the topics that you
are looking at at the moment
yes so really useful really powerful
watch that space on chat GPT yes so
really good to use it to analyze your
competition
so once you've got your competition
analyzed you're then going to decide
what are the topics that you're going to
cover you're going to look at the focus
area of your blog it's very important if
you want to be successful with your blog
so here are some steps that you can go
through first of all you identify your
passion
you're identifying your interests yeah
so that's where you can sort of in
initially start at looking at the topics
that you want to cover you're then going
to look at okay who is my audience yeah
you're going to create your personas and
then you've looked at your competition
as well but then very important once
you've looked and identified a topic you
then need to check is is it popular is
it trending
because yeah you can write a top topic
about a fantastic subject but if nobody
is reading about it if nobody is talking
about it yeah then hey it what's it
gonna do for you so a really good tool
to look at what is trending in the world
at the moment it's a tool called Google
Trends
so you just saw Chet's GPT which is
conversational AI so let's have a look
at is conversational AI a Hot Topic on
the internet Google Trends is a tool
that will give you how entrance about
how many people are searching for those
terms and the more people are searching
for it of course the more people are
interested about it the more exciting it
is and if I look at this term
from 2004 till today
yeah then you see immediately how hot
conversational artificial intelligence
is becoming and then particularly here
in the last couple of months this was
the November 2022 was when um chat GPT
launched its pre its product
and here you see the Stellar growth
on the topic yes so use conversation use
Google Trends to find out if your topic
is hot if your topic is trending
good so once you've looked at the
trending of your topic is it popular
you're then going to find your angle yes
so that is a key factor because there's
so many ways you can write about
conversational AI but what are the topic
or the subtopic what is the angle that
you're going to take
so basically to find out about the
angles on your topics then you of course
need to understand your Niche you need
to have a good understanding of your
Niche and the topics within your niche
again you're looking at your competitors
yeah so if there is a a certain sub
Niche yeah or a subtopic but everybody
has been writing about this then that is
not going to help you so you want to
find those areas within your Niche that
have not been explored yet
again look at your readers what do they
want to hear about what do okay you can
then adapt your writing to your readers
requirements and do simple things use
your own experiences and perspectives in
analyzing what you're going to write
about that can really help you in
finding a unique angle that sets you
apart from your competitors and
challenge yourself challenge the status
quo ask yourself questions that other
bloggers may not be asking be critical
but make sure that you found that unique
angle that you want to go for
right so now that we know the topic now
that we know the angle we're going to
start the block so the first thing we
need to do is to come up with a name for
the blog
yeah when you start thinking about
naming your blog you make sure you it is
descriptive
so make sure that the name of your blog
accurately describes the focused content
of your blog because that makes it
easier for the reader to understand what
your blog is all about
keep it simple don't use underscores or
hyphens keep the name simple avoid
overly complicated names that are
difficult to spell or remember
try to make your name unique yes so make
sure that your name sets you apart from
others in your niche think about SEO if
there's keywords that you can put in
your name of your blog yeah that can
really help
also very important to check if there is
a um if the URL is available for the
name of your blog because it's a
fantastic name but if there's no URL
available and I'll come back to that in
a minute and then of course ask people
ask Friends Ask customers what do you
think about the name of this blog and
use tools there's lots of naming tools
for your blogs yeah for for websites but
again if I go to chat GPT and I'll just
say give me 10 names for my new
CRM blog
chat GPT is going to give you fantastic
answers
yeah it just gives you ideas
so guys this chat GPT is going to
revolutionize the marketing profession
in the next few years and there's so
much more to come in this space
okay so that's where you go and have
your name for your blog and then check
the URL for the blog as well yeah so
once you've created your blog name you
need to create your blog domain and the
first thing you're going to do is is the
name available yes so
so here is a simple tool name Checker
and you can just type in the name so go
here to the name that we had yes so
let's say CRM Franca
and then we're going to go to
namechecker here we're typing CRM
Frontier
yep and we're just going to check is it
available as a.com
is it available on Facebook no is it
available on Twitter on Tumblr and you
see all the social channels and the.com
if it is available yeah and once it is
available you know that you're then
going to a
um a URL sort of place where you can buy
URLs and then you can
um go to your check if the name is
available there and you can go and buy
it so but we'll come back to that in a
minute so this is choose your name yeah
and make sure that your name is
available so then you're going to your
domain registrar so let's go to for
instance GoDaddy
yep so CRM Frontier is the name that we
wanted
so I'm going to put in the domain
see again if it is available search
domain
yeah and here you see CRM Frontier is
available for 714 and it's also
available as dot Co dot UK but you also
no one may want to look at am I going to
use dot info or Dot online or dot Inc or
dot TV so all the sessions that you need
to make the guideline here is that if
you are targeting a global market try to
go for the.com domain if you're
targeting a local market go for the
domain of that country like dot Co dot
UK for the UK yeah or dot ca for Canada
yeah so different ways of doing that but
that is the Golden Rule so we've checked
availability you can now register your
domain and then of course once you've
set up your blog you need to connect
your domain to your blog
good so that is the domain and the
domain registration
so if we go on the next thing you need
to do is choose a Content management
system
for your blog which is a very important
step in setting up your online presence
because with your CMS you actually
create your blog gone are the days where
you need to program in HTML yeah you now
have very simple blogging platforms like
WordPress or Wix yeah that can help you
in creating your website very important
in the decision for your CMS consider
the features that you need like blog
post creation blog post management user
management integration with other tools
and look at the important popular CMS
systems like WordPress or blogger or Wix
or Squarespace research them yep and
then ask jet GPT maybe which one that
you want to use look at ease of use yeah
there are free versions there are
premium versions check for support is
very important make sure that the
support as a chat availability that is
so much better when it comes to
productivity looks at at scalability and
look at cost as well a lot of web TMS
systems they may offer you a free
version to start with but then it will
have some basic advertising or you can't
use your own URL so very important that
you choose a CMS that works for you now
one of the most popular CMS that you can
use is WordPress
WordPress be aware there are two
versions of Wordpress there is
wordpress.com
which is a web development platform
which is hosted by WordPress so you
don't have to go to a provider like
GoDaddy and set up your website this is
all being done on WordPress
wordpress.com is the easiest platform to
get started with your own blog and
literally you can have your blog up and
running within 10 minutes
if you want to have a more professional
setup a more
um
long lasting a more powerful setup you
would go to wordpress.org and
wordpress.org you can only use through a
web internet service provider like
GoDaddy where you basically rent a
specific set of storage yep and that is
where you can install your own WordPress
installation
so that is wordpress.com and
wordpress.org so very important
decisions on starting your own WordPress
or your own development platform
and then finally you need to look at the
look and feel of your blog how are you
going to customize this so you need to
choose a theme for your blog yes so
because that can make or break your blog
and many blogging platforms they one of
the first questions they will ask you
what theme would you like to use for
your blog and let me show you very
simple one of the leading theme
platforms for your blog is envato yeah
there is theme forest seamforest.net and
you see here there's a whole library of
themes that you can choose for instance
I can say give me uh
um a Blog magazine yeah or give me other
topics yes so go back to all categories
so let's say let's go for a photography
blog
photography WordPress blog and then here
I'm getting a whole library of Wordpress
themes there are premium themes and
there are free themes as well but let's
take this first one
I can actually get a live preview of
that blog
yeah and then you see how the blog would
look like here you see the demos so
there would be demo one
yeah would be this one here
yeah so now it's actually loading this
theme and this is how your blog will
look like
yeah let's um close this one here
so here you see yeah you don't need this
one on the side here
but here you can see how the block would
look like
so
yep so really useful way of looking at
the deciding on the theme that you want
to use for your blog yeah so here you
see how the block would look
and then what you do when you go to
Wordpress you load the theme you load
the demo as well and then basically your
website is ready and the only thing you
have to do is change the photos change
the text and sort of tailor it to your
own visual Style
so there you have it very important yes
so
looking at the customization of your
blog by using themes that you can buy on
the internet out of a free or for a
premium
okay now I hope you have enough
knowledge now to make the decision
whether or not you're going to start a
blog let me give you a bit more details
about what is good about blogging what
is bad about blogging good about
blogging ish it's a great way to express
yourself and a great way to share your
thoughts
yeah it is really good to help you build
expertise if you write consistently
about your topic or your industry your
customers will start recognizing you as
an expert in your field and Google as
well so you can really use all that to
build your personal brand and on the
back of that promote your company
a blog is a really good platform to
build engagement with your following
through the commenting for instance or
through subscribing to your blog and
therefore it can build really good
networking opportunities for you and
connect with other bloggers and other
industry professionals so lots of
benefits that you can get from starting
a blog but there are negatives as well
don't think that when you start a blog
then that is a piece of cake and it's
going to take no time it takes time yeah
you need to commit to it and the worst
thing is that you start a blog and then
after three or four blog posts the blog
turns dead and then there's no updates
to your blog yeah so be committed to the
time that you want to put into this
it'll take time it's technical you need
to eat unless you go for a simple
platform like wordpress.com or Wix where
you don't have to worry about a
technical setup if you want to do it
professionally for your business you
need to have some technical
understanding on how to choose a
platform a hosting and the design of
your web
and the more technical it gets the more
costs are involved as well because with
the web hosting the domain name the
design and the security on your website
as well and getting your
um yeah so getting your uh your various
security certificates on your web
make sure that it's consistent you need
to be consistent with your content yeah
and keep your audience engaged and be
aware there is lots of competition out
there when you launch a block it doesn't
mean that all of a sudden everybody now
recognizes you as a blogger it takes
time it takes effort it takes
consistency yeah and it also it makes
sure that you stand out with your blog
from your competition and when you do
all that I am sure you're going to be
successful with your blog you're going
to be seen as an expert in your field
you're going to really enjoy blogging
about your hobby or about your passion
and I hope I gave you lots of tips here
on how to do that we'll do some more
about blocking in some of the next
videos on how to actually set up your
blog but for now that's a wrap thank you
for your time if you liked the video
don't forget to press the like button if
you want to join our community yeah just
click on the Subscribe button and we'll
see you at the next video so have a
great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here